so jordan one of the things that you
talk about in the book which is i think
really wonderful and and i hadn't heard
you talk about it a lot before
you've done in some of your lectures but
it hasn't been the main theme it's sort
of the relationship
question you know how do you maintain
romance in your relationship and as a
dude who's been married for almost 13
years
at this point i can say that you know it
is very very good advice i mean the
amount of work that has to go into a
relationship to keep a relationship
functioning at a high level
is tremendous and that's not what you
are sold in the media what you're sold
in the media
is number one the happily ever after
wedding ending
but even that is now hacked now the idea
is that there is no happily ever after
that basically you're a fool if you get
married and that true happiness lies
in changing partners on a fairly routine
basis but that's not the case that you
make at all you make the case that
happiness is going to lie and
fulfillment more importantly is going to
lie in the hard work of
of putting romance into your
relationship and and people i think
when they get into this thing they don't
know how much work it is
to even do the sort of thing where you
plan you have to plan
romance into your life particularly
after you have kids it's a reality
i had a lot of clinical experience you
know and i had
men in my practice who were very
successful
serial
serially sexually active and
it didn't work for them very well now i
would say
very forthrightly if i had
two men and all other things being equal
one was capable of serial sexual
relationships and was attractive enough
to manage that and the other wasn't that
the person who
managed to do that is more successful i
believe that
so if you're abstinent because you're
incapable that is not a virtue
but you can't divorce something
as miraculous
as sexuality from your life how are you
gonna do that
well you can trivialize it it's nothing
well okay well then then
then you have nothing so good luck with
that
you're going to take one of the deepest
sources of meaning that's available to
you
and turn it into nothing well
that's its own punishment well
so then you integrate it into your life
well what do you want for your life dude
i mean
do you want to be what what is what is
it that you want from sex
do you want intimacy do you want
closeness do you even want the
experience to be of high quality do you
want the person to pay
attention to you well they're gonna have
to care for you
i mean lust will get you somewhere and
it's not nothing
but but it's by no means everything
and and everyone knows this people are
lonely
they need and they need someone to
communicate with and they need someone
to
tie themselves together with so their
lives make a rope they need someone to
communicate
with when times are good and to share
their triumphs and they need someone to
share their catastrophes and they need a
framework
that's stable so that they can have
children and well why would you have
children it's like
that's a stupid question it's like well
what else are you gonna do you know i
mean
there aren't that many things that make
up your life and intimate relationships
that's
twenty percent of your life or thirty
percent of your life children that's
twenty percent of your life
now you can get away with neither of
those but you better have a walloping
career
or a tremendous aptitude at something
creative and remarkable and maybe you
can do that
maybe that'll be enough for you but i've
seen that
unidimensionality work out well very
very
very very very rarely so
and you have children because you won't
have you'll never have the opportunity
in your life to have as high quality
relationship with anyone as you could
potentially have with your child
so you're gonna forego that well you can
but
what's left for you then all this
cynicism
it you know what it's aimed against
blind obedience it's like fair enough
okay so i would take a cynic over
someone who's blindly obedient any day
especially a cynic who was once blindly
obedient
because at least then they had managed
that but
if you're really cynical you move past
cynicism
you doubt your doubt and you start to
notice
and then you engage in your life and so
young people are being sold a shoddy
bill of goods
even if you're successful at what you
pursue say
serial sexual satisfaction tinder you're
a hot tinder item
it's like well if you're a male and
you're attractive and you have an
endless array of willing females
it's a gateway to psychopathy as far as
i'm concerned
because you have to divorce your
sexuality
from the humanity of the people that
you're
engaged with sexually well all that's
going to do is make you hard and bitter
and i wouldn't recommend it so
and it's not casual moralizing
you know i'm not suggesting that
naive abstinence is the right solution
but we're not doing a good job ben of
of communicating the fundamental values
of life to you our young people i got a
story to tell you man
i talked to this woman this week yawn me
park and
she wrote a book called in order to live
she's an escapee from
north korea and like she had quite the
life man like
starvation then slavery was that kind of
sums up her life
she had to sell her own mother whom she
loved
you just think about that for like 15
minutes to see where it gets you
and and she was literally a slave in
china and
she struggled through all that ended up
in south korea and went to a south
korean
university she did all her education in
one year
elementary junior high and high school
in one year passed the ged and got into
a competitive south korean university
it's like this is quite the girl
and she her book it wraps up in 2015. so
i asked her about
what's happened in recent years she went
to columbia university
so imagine this girl struggles out of
north korea
and slavery and pursues her education
and gets to go to an
ivy league school in new york it's like
the pinnacle of her ambition
she was drastically affected by george
orwell's night
uh animal farm when she was in south
korea it's one of the first
classic books she read and that's what
made her decide to write and to speak
so she can understand the value of the
humanities like
virtually no one else can she went to
colombia
i said well how was that she said
it was a complete waste of time and
money and i said well wait a second
you can't you can't really mean that
surely
in your four years studying humanities
at columbia you must have had
one professor or one course that spoke
to you
you know the way that the books that you
were reading spoke to you that
that the person made the attempt to push
past the
limitations of the institution and and
mentored you
she mentioned one human biology class
where she learned about evolution but
said that that was all twisted by
political correctness near the end
and that was all she could muster up for
four years of
of she said that she felt just about as
stymied in her freedom of speech
at columbia university studying
humanities as she did in bloody north
korea
that's what we're doing to our young
people it's so
appalling so appalling
there's so much that people can be
offered
this richness of the past so much that's
desperately necessary this isn't
optional
the idea that man does not live by bread
alone
that's not religious claptrap
thank you for tuning in to the daily
wire one of the fastest growing
conservative media outlets in the
country
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a like and subscribe to our
youtube channel
so you don't miss out on any of our
content